Alan thank you very much I will ask you
to stand by again because we must talk
about diplomacy blinkin is coming to
Israel tomorrow I will first detour
though uh by Washington because US
President Joe Biden has confirmed more
than 70 Americans with dual citizenship
have left Gaza that comes after the Rafa
border crossing with Egypt temporarily
opened on Wednesday
listen we got out today 74 American
folks uh out uh that are C coming anyway
thank you okay thank
you okay let's bring in Mike Hannah in
Washington DC uh Mike that was a shouted
question so the information more than 70
Americans that's Palestinian Americans
have been able to leave Gaza that's one
of the priorities obviously for
Washington is to get their Nationals out
of this war
zone yes indeed the state department in
recent days has been saying that it's
focusing on that getting duel American
Palestinian citizens out of Gaza if this
appears now to be the case the president
answering that shouted question there
saying that 74 uh have been removed from
Gaza the details of how this actually
happened still not very clear whether
there was a pause in the hostilities to
allow them to get out how it was
actually done none of these details have
been made clear as yet but good news is
what President Biden described it as and
we waiting for further details on
exactly how this happened and indeed
when it happened now Biden is also
sending his secretary of state uh
Anthony blinkin to Israel for the second
time since uh the War Began blinkin said
that he would discuss steps to minimize
civilian casualties and that the US is
determined to prevent a wider escalation
let's listen to the US Secretary of
State
okay I thought we had that sound bite by
Anthony blinkin um we are working on
that we'll play that for you shortly um
I'm told it I'm told we have it
now we're focused on the day of we also
uh need to be focused on the day after
and so in conversations that U we'll be
having through the course of this this
weekend uh I expect you'll see a focus
there and particularly how we can get
over time two two states for two peoples
which in our judgment Remains the best
guarantor and maybe the only guarantor
of a secure Jewish and Democratic Israel
and uh Palestinians with the state uh
that they're entitled
to so Mike this is the other
conversation that Americans say that
they want to have with Israelis right
now I mean number one is how the
Israelis conducting the war and the
Americans want to um urge them to
minimize civilian casualties but they
also have this ambitious big picture
conversation that apparently they want
to have with the Israelis now as this
war is being prosecuted what's what's
the
idea well this is the first time we've
heard from the US Administration since
this conflict began in terms of
discussing what happens after
everything's been focused on the day as
the secretary of state would put it
nobody's been looking or talking about
the day after all of a sudden we've now
got the Secretary of State on his way to
Israel saying one of the things he's
going to be discussing in Israel is what
happened next talking about creating a
lasting pieace a lasting pieace which in
blinken's View and the US
administration's view is embedded in one
concept and that is the two-state
solution this is something uh that has
been the Bedrock of us diplomacy with
regards to Israel for a long period of
time but now blinking bringing this up
as well I must add as well as is that
those aren't the other only things that
uh blinkin was talking about or indeed
White House officials have been talking
about in the course of the day the
question of sensations of hostilities
now that's being talked about little
fragments of time in which it will allow
people to get out and humanitarian
supplies to get in uh blinkin it is said
is going to be discussing this whole
question of ceasefires or a pause in
hostilities which would be dependent on
location which would be dependent on
duration it seems to be envisioned as a
whole series of a pause to hostilities
imp particular areas in particular times
given the circumstances on the ground of
getting people out and getting
humanitarian supplies in so a lot of
developments a lot of information uh
coming out in the course of the day uh
clearly the secretary of state has a lot
to talk about with the Israeli Prime
Minister all of a sudden bringing in not
only what is going to happen during the
the conflict how the Israelis actually
conduct that conflict with regard to
civilian casualty whether or not the
Israelis are going to pause the
conflicts at particular times to allow
humanitarian supplies in and then of
course that overarching thing which has
suddenly come out it seems from nowhere
uh that there's a return to talk about
two-state Solutions lasting agreements
lasting peace yeah seems to come out of
nowhere as you say um Mike Hannah
reporting from Washington DC thank you
very much we want to talk about that
precise question with Al shazir senior
political analyst Marwan bishara um I'm
very happy that you're back with us here
in Doha in the studio because we we we
need to have these
conversations so the Americans started
their action in this conflict by
expressing full-fledged support for
Israel they have a right not just a
right but a duty to defend themselves
and very emotional Language by the US
president um
now their their tone has changed and
they're saying one of our priorities as
we go to Israel is to discuss a lasting
solution to the conflict they've been at
this for decades the two-state solution
I mean it they've been at this for
decades where do you think this is going
is this political expediency do they say
this because they have to say this or do
they say this because there is a moment
that can be seized upon to actually move
towards peace when President Biden uh
arrived in Israel and gave uh prime
minister Netanyahu that Infamous
hug uh when uh when the Prime Minister
basically blocked the Israeli president
in order for him to get that Embrace by
the American president that wasn't a
classic hug that wasn't
Bromance that was a bear hug the
American president came to Israel his
visit was a bear hug what is a bear hug
a bear hug is when you tell someone who
is in
trouble as you embrace them very very
closely you tell them don't worry I will
protect you I've got you but down the
road you owe me that's the bear hug
presumably America has given Israel
numerous Bear Hugs along the way over
the past 55 years the problem with
Israel unlike other countries say for
example Ukraine or Iraq or any which
country is that Israel has that leverage
in
Washington that it gets the arms it gets
the money but when it comes to the
advice it tells Washington no no no we
can manage ourselves we know what is our
national security this time around
President Biden has been insistent from
the very beginning that his bear hug is
not another bear hug he's been saying is
look we've come all the way for you we
used our Leverage diplomatically
strategically we deployed two aircraft
carriers we replen your armaments we are
100% behind you there is no daylight
between us if you do succeed in this war
against Gaza which the Americans think
they will then you're going to have to
deliver for us on the Diplomatic
front
so am I as I listen to you um
is it fair then to believe is there a
reason to believe that this war for as
bloody and tragic as it is and for the
as many civilians as have already died
and as many more civilians are going to
die more than likely in this war are you
telling us that it actually could open a
window which hasn't been opened in a
very long time for real sincere peace
negotiations
what maybe we're getting ahead of
ourselves we're getting ourselves let's
just back back backtrack just a little
bit just a little bit Biden before this
visit in October was was was in in
Israel Palestine before after he became
president and he told president Abbas
the Palestinian president he told him
forget about a two-state solution this
is not the time for a two State solution
President Biden couldn't even muster
opening the American Consulate in East
Jerusalem in order to serve the
Palestinian side he could
basically count on anything when it
comes to Israel because of the Netanyahu
government and its predecessor
government so right-wing so fascist so
fanatic that basically the Americans
couldn't use their leverage with Israel
and Israel has such leverage in the
American Congress that basically you
couldn't push Israel around be that as
it may now the question is one of two I
hope it's the second the first is Biden
is basically covering up for Israel as
it is finishing its genocide because we
are already you and I and the rest of us
rushing to talk about the day after but
we are still in today and genocide is
unraveling today and Biden and blinkin
are still giving cover to Israel
diplomatic and otherwise and the
promises of Peace in order for Israel to
continue with this genocide that's one
possibility the second possibility is
the one we just addressed is that
Americans are serious they are sick and
tired of this conflict continuing under
their own opes they have tried for 30
years since Oso started in
1993 to bring an end to this conflict
which is the Israeli occupation of
Palestine and they have not succeeded is
this the chance for them to actually be
honest for a change and actually apply
the necessary pressure and The Leverage
that they now have with
Israel in order to bring peace remains
to be
seen I I've got another question for you
but I want to go to Alan Fischer and
occupied East Jerusalem um just before I
come back to you Alan I I'd like to find
out you you've been listening to these
conversations and also of course you are
preparing to report on this new
diplomatic Tour by Anthony blinkin the
US Secretary of State as he when he
arrives in Israel tomorrow how do you
think he's going to be received
well of course he'll be given a bear hug
just like maran's been talking about
they'll thank him for his support
remember he was here twice in October he
did a a visit around the region he was
meant to be here for 48 hours and he end
up staying 8 days he facilitated Joe
Biden's visit here which was uh widely
regarded as as a success and certainly
set the template for other world leaders
to come to Tel Aviv or Jerusalem and
express their support but he's got
difficulties because he wants to perhaps
talk about some sort of more
humanitarian Aid getting in and that's
difficult unless there is a ceasefire
and he's already told Congress when he
gave evidence on the hill earlier this
week that a ceasefire would help Hamas
so that is a nonstarter he also wants to
address the fact that Israel is
conducting this war and civilians are
dying with the numbers going up every
hour and he wants to talk to them about
conducting the war in the limits of
humanitarian law human rights law and
the the laws of war but he's got a
problem because Benny Gant who's often
considered the most moderate member of
of the war cabinet has said in the last
couple of hours that Israel will act in
accordance with what is right for Israel
Benjamin Netanyahu has in the last hour
told soldiers that they are at the gates
of Gaza and they will continue to go
forward they will not stop so the the
idea of getting some sort of break in
the fighting seems almost for laoren and
he would like to discuss what's going to
happen the day after the day after Hamas
Falls if Israel is successful in this
war and one of the things they've been
talking about is perhaps setting up some
sort of international Force but who
would do that the Americans don't want
boots on the ground certainly not in an
election year that would be a disaster
for Joe Biden because the Americans
would become targets ask other Arab
Nations the other Arab nations would
think that that's almost giving a rubber
stamp to what Russia is to do what
Israel is doing and and so there are all
these problems stacking up for him now
one of his under secretaries has been in
the region for the last few days
smoothing out uh what's going to happen
here and as we've talked about before
presidents secretaries of State like to
come away with what they can call
deliverables so Anthony blinkin would
like to be able to leave Israel and say
well at least we got this but at the
moment it seems like whatever he's
facing is an up P task Alan thank you
very much for all that reporting this
hour from occupied to East Jerusalem uh
Marwan just before I come back to you an
important update for our viewers the
Israeli military now saying that they
have encircled Gaza City okay so the
information we had up until just this
moment was that they were on the edges
the outskirts of Gaza City which
obviously is the biggest city in the
Gaza Strip they're now saying that they
have encircled Gaza City we'll try and
break that down bring you more meaning
on that context first though Marwan that
question that I've been wanting to ask
you since I was listening to Allan he
mentioned that it's a a presidential
election year in the US today's November
2nd November 5th
2024 is the next US presidential
election so almost to the day a year
from now so Biden is heading into this
election year he obviously wants to be
reelected he's
running that's going to be one of the
main pressures that he's going to have
to factor in um as he you know as the US
weighs its position in this conflict
does that you think make a serious push
for peace in the Israeli Palestinian
conflict more likely or less
likely I know you're not going to like
my answer but I'm going to have to do I
always like your what is
right it's too early too early to tell I
tell you why it's only too early not
just because the elections are next year
it's too early because we don't know
what's going to happen the next 48 hours
M as Biden loves to say and I'm quoting
M President Biden now we are at an
inflection point now in Gaza in the
region the next 40 hours 40 are going to
be
decisive now let me tell you why I am an
adamant viewer of Israeli
TV although I don't watch TV in general
but I have been the past 20 days
watching Israeli TV only the past 24
hours I've noticed a change of tone in
the Israeli generals and Military
commment ators starting to boast about a
potential victory in Gaza what you call
encircling Gaza now they are talking
about The Siege within the siege so
they've sieged Gaza since 16 17 years
now they see now they besieged Gaza City
that's where they think the action is
against the Palestinian resistance so
the next 48 48 Hours could either open
the way for Gates of
Hell of of many many many people die
including a lot of
Israelis although Israelis are using
their heavy armaments their tanks and
for the first time they are boasting of
using the most sophisticated American
Technology whereby a soldier on the
ground now have instant connection with
the with the with the with the jet
fighters in the air so they can advance
together this is the first time in
Israel's military history that they are
able to use the most advanced American
Technology technology in order to
advance in Gaza but the resistance is
still in Gaza and something else is
opening up as we've heard from our
corespondent in South Lebanon is that
this is come also becoming an inflection
point now we're having Kon being hit in
the northern Israel tomorrow the head of
Hezbollah is going to make his big
speech whether this also is going to
mean heating up the borders with with in
South Lebanon as it heats up in Gaza
City with
Bloodshed on the gate we don't know
exactly how will it go smooth and
basically Gaza breaks down and falls
apart and Israel just invades the entire
territory and perhaps push a number of
Palestinians to
Sinai or will it
actually proceed for a number more days
or weeks of Street to street
fight then the Bloodshed and the tragedy
might not reflect very Welling the
American president what was happen in
the meanwhile secretary blink is coming
to the region hoping to talk about the
day after he's probably going to be
meeting with Arab foreign ministers in
Jordan that's to my
knowledge in in order to discuss the day
after if the if the fighting continues
in Gaza and another front opens in South
Lebanon then Arab foreign ministers are
going to be quite wary of taking
anything the American president takes
seriously at this point in time now that
GE is pulling back Ambassador bahin is
pulling back his Ambassador if this is
going to go on for another two months
I'm not sure Jordan Lebanon and a number
of other countries will be able to hold
back for too long it's all to answer
your question so your answer was it's
too soon to tell watch the next 48 hours
watch this space okay I'll take that
I'll take that as an answer Marwan we're
not letting you go anywhere you're
staying with us even though we're taking
a very short break